and you have to watch the same as if it's
cooking because you don't want to miss
[Music]
and
this
twist street sound fabián and we have
two rules the first time that I
'm only going to speak to you in Spanish the
second time what we're going to cook list
[Laughter
] what we are going to do now
now we are going to cook a dish that comes
in el salvador includes things that we have
here we have meat, beans, cheese, masa and a
lot of vegetables but I don't have to say what
we are going to do because we are going to see
when we finish there  a
couple of cheese
first we are going to cut the meat and it is going to
drop that cutting board
cheer up if you have to cut it we are going to
cut it into cubes
be careful with your fingers
you have to turn on the stove it is
perfect to put it on 5 but right now 5 1 2
3  7 5
later we are going to put oil like this but
not much just a little bit of oil
perfect
teaspoon
[Laughter]
perfect and we are going to put the meat in
here and we are going to cook it and then
we are going to use another board to cut the
whole v  erdura and pointer or disco 'with and
ghana that have the wildcard brown
this is
fine we proceed what we are going to do is
we are going to israel to be safe if we have to
leave it on this side here for 15 minutes
and then we are going to turn it around for 15
minutes  if he knows like a party that he
is godfather 15 15
and above
then you are going to turn it around to listen to him
perfect
and this has to be cut
shorter like this and we are going to put the
little pieces inside the meat to
blend it
we are only going to do half  but
I'm going to come back here even though they're half
perfect
tomato
and then how to finish or not
inside here af there's a pre-new cartonero and
then we're going to put it in a blender
we're going to blend
it you didn't understand me
understand where they are
later we're going to have to cut the
onion
perfect
so right
now you have to turn it over to check
if it's ready,
tell me, turn it over, shake me in it
[Music]
I don't know what this descent is called
but we're going to use them
when we finish  cook the meat
we are going to put all the vegetables
and we are going to make something like a joke this is
going to stay a little bit as it is
but not so much and it
does not stop moving the
same thing I think it is ready
we can turn off the stove turn it off
later  we are going to put it in an art plate
and if you can put all the little pieces
inside this formal plate,
to blend it this has to be
put inside here
after the
tomato onion
well
you have to move the meat in this
soup plan before
if you understand what you are  I am saying
and you say no but I say yes
everything I am saying
first we are going to use four glasses of
dough with more dough and with fire
then we are going to add 2 teaspoons
of salt we are going to mix the key knicks
with love
later  of this you have to put more or
less three glasses of water are suitable by
itself and from here it begins to administer it
until it becomes a little like bar bar
is like clay
[Music]
and
mixed
are planned stores used so that l  the
dough does not stick to your hands we use
oil and a little water
efe
she knows what it has to be you have to
take out a little piece
and make it into a ball first yes it
starts like crushing them julie we
do it like this
and
we say palm tree
you're ready  not to put food
inside it we are going to put a little
pork rind
and put a little cheese
and then a little beans
yes and from here he tries to enclose it like a
trampoline but here it is next to the lipstick
and he also uses his hand to close it like this
it was
done we started to crush it the other
time perfect
there is no more voting station
[Laughter]
and my grandmother puts a little of this
a little bit of water and closes them with the
gene they noticed
you can continue crushing the palm
until it is  they do more like hanks and
when a little more oil and water
traditionally we use some they did
with a bad example of germs but since
we are here in the kitchen it exists and we are going
to use this
first let's go
a little bit per  or do you have to use something here
to put the two sides
like this and if a lot of people don't like it when they
come out greasy huawei
[Music]
[Music
] white changed and even if I know to be
a little whiter they
shouldn't be so burnt and  guanaja for
golden brown hallows and
[Music]
and
my former lieutenant his team from miami
where the team between games and 4 because
knight and day
admitted work in team activism I think
he looks good and active to put him
on the plate
oh
for the great  In the end, the pupusas are eaten
with something called curtido and many
people put it on top of the proposal,
but I like it next to it, the thing is
that if we are crops, bring
chicken vinegar 3 carrots and other
countries today it says chicken cabbage
because it's called cabbage and it's not chicken
, you can scoop it out with a spoon or
even with your hands, that's fine, that's
still fine
in the exhaust
and
it
dies despite thanks from square
and
i
[Laughter]
or
[Music]